my first reaction on reading the paper
was no this is wrong something's wrong
they're going to think this is crazy
this is outrageous I still don't believe
you probably it really is a paradigm
shift in terms of when humans arrived on
this car and if it does turn out to be
true it changes
we're excited about the publication of a
research project we've been working on
for a few years that I guess in a
nutshell we could call the oldest
archaeological site here in North
America I first visited the site the day
it was discovered I was called by
Richards Rudy a field paleontologist
here at the Museum that he had
discovered what he thought was a mammoth
that a freeway construction site that he
was monitoring we started realizing
early on that there was some odd aspects
with the skeleton first of all it was a
mastodon not a mammoth but we also found
pieces of sharply broken rocks such as a
specimen this was actually the first
rock specimen that we Richard discovered
and that was an association with sharply
broken bones of this Mastodon I mean
this is part of a leg bone of a mastodon
and then we also found a large rock in
association with these bones which poses
a puzzle because the remains of this
Mastodon were found in a silt layer and
geological processes that would deposit
silt are not going to be depositing or
carrying rocks of this size and so we're
looking at this and thinking well how
did those rocks get there what makes
sense to us although it's it's out there
is that the hypothesis suggesting that
humans brought these rocks to this site
and that humans used these rocks to
break bone like this it wasn't until
2012 that we had really reliable dates
that the site was as old as 130,000
years
it's hundred thousand years older than
the broadly accepted dates for the first
occupation of the Americas now as far as
we understand from things like genetics
and the archaeology people move into the
Americas some time maybe twenty three
thousand years ago or less and they come
across the Bering Straits and these are
the ancestors of all the modern first
nation peoples of the Americas today one
hundred and thirty thousand years ago
it's different the sea laying in between
the two continents between North East
and Siberia and between Alaska is wider
so that's one problem with this how do
we get humans across and the other
question is which humans are they going
to be so there are a number of
possibilities but until we actually find
skeleton actly site or at the size of a
comparable age in America's it's all
open to speculation and we just don't
know so for the archaeologists say that
it's outrageous how can this be there's
really no evidence other than this one
site that the humans were here 130,000
years ago I mean one of the answers to
that question is that well if
archaeologists aren't looking in rocks
or sold so how can they find evidence if
they're not looking in the right place
whether the others for human to human
interaction with the site is convincing
or not to be honest with you I'm a
little skeptical my failing stone tools
and I look at the pictures of the stones
from there I put them against the fact
that there are no native stone tools
around there at all and for me that
starts to ring alarm bells a little I
suspect it along when most people will
want to see it more rigorously
investigated so are the stone tools
really properly bashed or is there some
explanation for it is there bashing on
their bones genuinely what they think of
course there are other ways to break
bone besides just smashing them with a
rock but as we examined closely the
specimens that we had from our site we
found no no marks that were consistent
with those kinds of
our alternative hypothesis and we even
experimented with replicating how bones
break and took hammer stones and broke
elephant bone to see what kind of damage
that caused to the bones and the pattern
of breakage was consistent with what we
found at the our site here in San Diego
there have been stranger discoveries in
archaeology how implausible is 130,000
well maybe it's not completely
impossible but I think it's it's less
about filling in of a gap than an
opening of a whole new chapter